Bolivian soldiers and the country's
indigenous people welcomed Pope Francis
at el alto airport he was joined by
President Evo Morales who held his fist
in the air in a salute the Pope then
traveled on to the capital lapaz where
he addressed the crowds outside the
presidential palace the pontiff chose to
visit three of South America's poorest
countries Ecuador Bolivia and Paraguay
to raise awareness of dire poverty
levels in the region the city Cathedral
turned into a sea of cell phones as the
pontiff made his way to the altar the
congregation clamored to take a
photograph of the continents first pope
after lapaz the Pope flew to Santa Cruz
where he began his whistle stop tour he
addressed the issue of integrating
different ethnic groups in the socialist
country Bolivia estudando pesos in
Bolivia is making important steps
towards including broad sectors in the
country's economic social and political
life your Constitution recognizes the
rights of individuals minorities and the
natural environment followers even slept
on the streets to catch a glimpse of
Francis on his so-called homecoming tour
you